what's going on guys this is rob and
i've been thinking about avengers king
dynasty and avengers secret wars and it
got my mind going in this direction of
asking the question are we going to see
more variance potential variants of
characters that we already know so then
i started thinking if we did what are
like 10 versions of iron man that we
could see
in avengers secret wars in kang dynasty
or kang dynasty and secret war so here's
10 variants that that we could see or
that i want to see in this movie but
before we do that we have to thank the
sponsor of this video atlas vpn so right
now atlas vpn has this deal going on
where you can get their service for like
a dollar 83 a month like
that's a ridiculously good deal and for
those of you all who are not familiar
with vpns this is called a virtual
private network what this means is that
when you don't have a virtual private
network and you get on your computer and
you browse the internet your actual ip
address from your house can be seen with
a virtual private network what you do is
you make it look like you're actually
somewhere else now i use atlas vpn for a
couple different reasons the first one
is because of something called
geo-restricting those you guys who don't
know what that means when it comes to
different streaming services out there
oftentimes what they do is they restrict
content based on your geographic
location now in the states it's not
necessarily an issue and so far as like
what you can see in california you can
see in texas but say for example that
you were taking a trip to spain and you
wanted to stay caught up on your shows
you might not be able to see those shows
because you're in spain whereas if you
have a vpn you can basically get around
that another reason why i use atlas vpn
and in this day and age i feel like this
is an incredibly important thing is
because of their data breaching monitor
feature basically meaning that what the
software does is it continually scans
the internet to see whether or not your
personal information has basically been
the subject or been a victim of a giant
data breach that exists out there which
seems to happen more and more frequently
but based on those two things alone i
found atlas vpn to be more than worth
the dollar 83 a month so make sure you
guys check out the link down in the
description make sure you grab your copy
of atlas vpn and let's get back into the
video
and starting with the first one we got
to go with iron man from earth x now
here's the thing when it comes to earth
x the story is less about iron man and
more about like an entire universe but
it would be cool to see because one of
you guys who don't know earth x was a
story that was written in 1999 and it
actually is part of a three-part series
called universe x and paradise x the
other two i need to cover over comics
explain we did cover earth x if you want
to go check it out but the general just
behind this is for those of you guys who
saw like eternals the nature in which
celestials are born in eternals that was
started in earth x eventually jonathan
hickman rolled that over into a shield
miniseries and that became the main way
in which celestials are born in the main
marvel universe but the idea behind that
is there was essentially a celestial
that was going to be born in earth and
that what it did is it led to a
circumstance where initially the
inhumans wanted to conquer the earth and
so when they left attilan and they they
kind of spread throughout the rest of
the world itself that humanity started
attacking in humans thinking they were
mutants and the inhumans were being
killed all over the place now most of
that's due to the fact that the inhumans
suck and so what ended up happening is
the inhumans wanted basically wanted to
leave the earth but when they did they
were going to essentially set things up
so that they could come back in a future
point in time and essentially rule it
and so black bolt detonated the terrigen
bomb spread terror genesis throughout
the world but when that happened it
basically ended up merging with all the
toxins and stuff in the earth's
atmosphere and it started activating
mutant powers and that's where you got
mutants from in the earth x universe now
this led to essentially everybody on
earth developing abilities by one way or
another for tony stark he was one of the
few who actually remained safe from it
and the way he did that was actually
enclosing himself in what was
essentially avengers man or i'm sorry uh
the iron mansion to a degree but
basically kept himself hidden away from
the world eventually norman osborne
became president and tony stark allied
himself with osborne if for no other
reason than to destroy him from
basically the inside out and then just
kind of became a recluse and then
eventually sacrificed himself at the end
of the story not a whole lot going there
but it would be pretty cool to see kind
of an older grizzled looking iron man
obviously we're starting from the least
interesting working our way to the most
interesting after that of course there
is what's basically thor core iron man
right so this is i guess number two if
we're going in order whatever this order
is right thor core iron man is cool now
much like earth x iron man the main
story itself is not so much about iron
man but it is a cool depiction of iron
man and the whole reason behind this is
that in secret wars in 2015
that what marvel did is they gave us the
main secret war story but they also gave
us a whole bunch of tie-ins and one of
these was thor core now while the main
secret war story dealt with the idea of
doctor doom becoming god king doom and
essentially ruling the entirety of
battle world because he didn't want to
have to like control everything going on
all the time that what he did is he
created a police force so essentially
all these different uh territories right
these different uh worlds on battle
world itself or these different land
masses whatever you want to call them
they basically were allowed to appoint
individuals who would actually travel to
the citadel of the thor corps and they
would try to lift the hammer of a thor
right a single mjolnir and if they could
do it they would be inducted into the
thor corps if they weren't they'd be
sent back to their home and so iron man
was one of the individuals out there
from one of these many places that was
able to lift the lift the hammer of thor
and became a member of the thor court
now one of the things i want to specify
is this was not a particular iron man of
significance it wasn't like it was iron
man from the main marvel universe or the
ultimate universe or anything like that
it was just a iron man that existed out
there but it was an alternate reality
iron man who possessed the hammer of
thor and so he literally looked like
iron man with the thor garb and it
looked really cool right we don't get a
whole lot of him but it looked really
really cool so i would love to see a
version specifically this part of the
thor core if the thor core exists in
that world and they can make it work by
whatever manner they want to but the
third one on our list here and again
this is more about exploring universes
than particular versions of iron man
we'll get into like the really cool iron
man here in a second the age of
apocalypse iron man now a lot of people
don't know about this story it came out
during the 1990s the idea behind this is
that you had a guy named david holler
also known as legion and the whole gist
behind this story is that legion took it
upon himself to go back in time and to
basically kill magneto because magneto
had made life hell for his father
charles xavier and the idea was that if
he killed magneto it'd make it easy for
xavier with the x-men and all that kind
of stuff xavier jumps in the way he dies
and because there are no x-men when the
villain apocalypse makes his move to
conquer the world that he basically
starts conquering north america setting
his sights on the rest of the world and
so what you have is kind of a ragtag
x-men team if you want to call it that
it's led by magneto but it's not really
the x-men as you know it right there
nowhere near as organized as the
traditional x-men that we know and
actually they're nowhere near as
powerful but one of the cool things
about this is that humanity at least
those who managed to escape the united
states before they fell under the
tyrannical rule of apocalypse had gone
to europe iron man was on a group called
the human high council so essentially he
was one of the few humans that actually
had a governing hand with regards to how
they were going to handle north america
if i remember correctly they were going
to nuke it like they were just going to
nuke north america and just be like you
know what i'm sorry americans it's time
to go you know and that was basically it
it would have been the end of end of
america which i feel like most of the
world wants to do right now but that
would have basically been it right north
america would have been nuked and that
would have been the end of it i want to
say they continue the age of apocalypse
on in secret wars from 2015 i don't
recall exactly how it happened but the
important thing here is that while it
would give us a cool alternate reality
version of iron man it would actually
give us a universe whereby mutants had
essentially or at least mutants have
kind of banded together and under the
rule of apocalypse had conquered north
america because a lot of the characters
they're kind of change-ups they're not
really characters as you know them
nightcrawler for example as opposed to
being like very religious and really
kind of a bastion of hope among the
x-men the guy's really dark like
juggernaut is a monk just all kinds of
crazy stuff like that right juggernaut
was enormous in that story and yeah he
was definitely a monk but it would be
cool to see that version of iron man
there now to get into the cool ones to
get into the cool versions of iron man
that i know you guys all want to see so
the first one that i would want to see
here is armor wars iron man from secret
wars 2015. so here was the idea behind
this what you had was something called
technopolis so in in this alternate
reality from secret wars 2015 that
essentially you ended up learning that
what howard stark had done is he had
actually developed stark tech before
tony stark did right so instead of tony
stark being the one to develop the iron
man suit it was really howard stark who
had done it but what he had done is that
in order to ensure this the success of
this suit he had designed that he had
created something called the technopolis
organic virus and what it did is it was
a virus that would actually infect a
portion of humanity which would require
them to wear the suits of howard stark
in order to survive nobody would know
that's what happened they would suddenly
just know oh my god i'm sick and only
howard stark suits can save me what
ended up happening is the the
technopolis organic virus ended up
spreading throughout the world and
basically infecting everybody so
everybody had to buy the suits of howard
stark now inevitably people would figure
out what was going on and what ended up
happening is that in order to ensure
that didn't take place tony stark had
basically installed what were called
inhibitor chips inside the different
suits that were given to people so that
whenever it was they started to wonder
where the techno-organic virus came from
it would basically make them forget and
then he basically scrapped all records
of anybody knowing what was going on now
what ended up happening of course is
like spider-man figured it out and then
tony stark killed spider-man in order to
keep it covered up it was a really
really cool thing right it was a really
really cool story i won't ruin anything
else for you guys but it was a great
concept you're definitely welcome to
check it out if you want to i think we
covered it over at comics explain but
that's a version of iron man that i want
to see right who comes from a world
where everybody has to wear his suits
otherwise they're basically going to die
now following that we get infamous iron
man now infamous iron man i know a lot
of you guys who read comics are just
like yes okay infamous iron man is
technically not tony stark it's actually
victor von doom but the idea behind this
is that in marvel comics during the the
terrible garbage ass event called civil
war ii which was a terrible cash grab by
marvel comics where they screwed the
pooch so bad that's one of those stories
that marvel tries to sweep under the rug
but we're not going to let him forget so
what ended up happening is that tony
stark actually died at the end of that
story i think he was killed by carol
danvers in what was some terrible
attempt by marvel comics to like make
things interesting for carol honestly
she hadn't been cool since kelly sue the
comics run but the thing about it is
that uh with tony stark dead and out of
the picture that victor von doom took up
the mantle of iron man and he was
amazing i would say infamous iron man is
probably the best iron man story that
had been written since the secret origin
of tony stark by kieran gillan right so
like well actually christopher
cantwell's runs uh run is really really
good i know this doesn't sound like a
geek culture explained video kind of
like a comic explain video but we're
talking about characters we could see in
the secret wars movie so we're making it
work it was a really really really cool
run right absolutely loved it but dr
doom as iron man it was actually kind of
his redemption story in a lot of ways
right where dr octopus got his
redemption story when he took over the
body of peter parker and ended up
becoming a good guy until he went back
to being a bad guy again that doctor
doom took over the the mantle of iron
man from tony stark oddly enough it's
one of those few instances where a
character took over the role of another
character took the name and nobody
complained
i don't know search me but it's one of
those things where it was just it was a
great storytelling phenomenal
storytelling and i absolutely loved it
right so a perfect example of selective
outrage from comic book fans but moving
on from that we get into what's
basically the the really like emperor
iron man now emperor iron man if you
haven't heard of him really it's more
emperor stark is what he's called this
is from an old comic called the exiles
so way back in the day in marvel comics
in order to keep things interesting
regarding the multiverse what they did
is they launched a story called the
exiles fascinating concept right
probably one of the coolest comic book
runs that marvel comics ever had that
basically the exiles were a multiversal
team of mutants that really just kind of
shifted around in terms of the roster
and all that kind of stuff but literally
there was a story after the events of
house of m this was not part of it this
was before that but it was a story from
after the events of house of m called
world tour where they went around to
like a world war hulk universe so like
what if world war hulk never ended
different things like that traveled to
like these different alternate realities
actually you know it was a world where
hookah was the future in perfect
universe where the uh where maestro hulk
the future version of banner that went
crazy after a global war uh ended up
creating like dystopia and all that kind
of stuff but they went to like the
marvel 2099 universe it was a really
really cool run but in issues number 23
through 25 what you got was this
alternate reality where essentially it
was the most dick version of iron man
ever right just like the most dick
version ever so what this guy had done
right think like v for vendetta with
this whole thing with the way the norse
fire party came came to power what tony
stark had done in this alternate reality
is he had orchestrated the downfall of
society by instigating the mutant war he
had worked directly alongside uh magneto
to essentially uh kind of initiate a war
between the mutant population and the
human population and the idea behind
this is that once the war was over that
a huge portion of the mutant population
would be annihilated right but what it
would do is it would allow for magneto
to rule everything and then for iron man
to operate as a kind of a grand region
for magneto over a section of humanity
instead iron man betrayed magneto and
killed him but it was recorded and so
because humanity saw this whole thing
happening live and because they knew
that magneto had led the mutant war
against humanity they saw iron man as a
hero who single-handedly ended the
mutant war now following that he was
basically elected to president of the
united states but then set his sights on
world domination so what he started
doing is he basically unleashed this
virus that destroyed all kinds of crops
and animal life across the world this is
so cool right it destroyed crops and
animal life across the world right but
then suddenly his the entirety of stark
industries popped up with like a cure
and while that was going on then you
basically had him using systems right
organizational structures or really kind
of like satellites and whatnot that were
basically creating natural disasters
across the world and only stark
industries had the ability to end these
natural disasters so it was a really
really crazy situation he basically kind
of put himself in a position to where
being this person that owned all these
different companies and then using those
companies to initiate economic collapses
across the world that it was like stark
industries was like the one person that
could save everybody and in times of
desperation people will believe what
they want to believe just look at
twitter in 2022. so what that meant is
that people were desperate for an answer
and they looked to stark industries to
save them and never really asked any
questions and as a result of that tony
stark successfully makes himself the
hero like the leader of the world now
for anybody who opposed him he killed
him right x-men avengers it didn't
matter any superheroes who stood against
them he annihilated them and the only
ones left were the inhumans he probably
kept him alive because he felt bad for
him because he and humans suck right so
it's like you know what let's let those
guys live they suck they're not really
that powerful it's not like they can do
anything anyway so like that was
basically it now following that we got
kind of a sort of one-off we didn't get
it very long but we basically got the
sorcerer supreme iron man which was
really really cool right now this is a
version of steven strange who's actually
from a what if story is earth 9810 it
was a story where dr stranger steven
strange had basically had the whole
accident that cost him the use of his
hands but tony stark was with him and so
tony stark who was actually driving at
the time ended up promising doctor
strange that they would find a way to
fix his hands and that they ended up
traveling to tibet and it was tony stark
who encountered the ancient one and that
tony stark ended up defeating baron
mordo and that he earned the title of
sorcerer supreme so thing of the origin
of doctor strange as you know it except
it was tony stark who became sorcerer
supreme and stephen strange was kind of
a side along guy and that was basically
it but it'd be great to see a version of
tony stark that became the sorcerer
supreme it'd be really really cool right
i'd be really excited and it's kind of a
bonus here because i think we've done 10
but i can't really remember off top my
head so as a bonus here no we're at nine
right now the last one that i want to
see right number 10 here the original
tony stark right like robert downey jr
tony stark i would love to see mcu iron
man make a return i think it'd be cool
right if for no other reason the fact
that we get an alternate reality that
unfolded pretty much the exact same way
as the the main model cinematic universe
has unfolded except maybe some small
difference some difference is small
enough that we can kind of say it's
basically the same universe and like
that's basically it right just kind of
call it a day but we basically get
robert downey jr returning as iron man
in some capacity i would love to see
that happen but for a bonus
number 11 for a bonus here
tom cruise is superior iron man i think
we can all agree that's the guy we want
to see next i think there's so much hype
and so much excitement does that mean
tom cruise's superior iron man is better
than robert downey jr's iron man no and
you'd be a fool to believe otherwise you
walk up to anybody out there right it's
just it's feels right it's the feels but
you walk up to anybody out there and you
ask the question you say hey uh who
would you want to see more here right
like robert downey jr's iron man return
or tom cruise as superior iron man
they're probably gonna say robert downey
jr iron man right just because you know
we love nostalgia so it was like we'd
love to see him come back i'd totally be
down with that but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
thank you all for watching make sure you
guys check out atlasvpn and i will catch
you all later
peace